hey know what time it is it's moving
retrospective time that's what time it
is yeah yeah going back to nineteen
eighty three actually one of my favorite
movies from the 1980s I had this on VHS
and I wore the [ __ ] out of it in fact I
don't even need notes for this [ __ ]
because I've seen this movie so many
times I essentially memorized I did
watch it again for this will it cos
shudder added it the other day this is
1983 s Christine yeah I read the book
saw the movie several times yeah same
here I didn't like it that much when I
first came out but then aged really well
I liked it on multiple viewings that
that was pretty cool it's funny because
this is one of those movies and it was
directed by John Carpenter yeah Christ's
sake yeah and it's one of those ones
that like for some reason like in the
80s I kept forgetting that it was a John
Carpenter movie it doesn't it doesn't
really feel like one it's a little more
expensive yeah and I guess it sort of
feels like one but it's like it was
something that I kept forgetting and I
feel like not only is this an underrated
John Carpenter movie it's also an
underrated Stephen King at it yeah one
of the better ones yeah because I mean I
don't know like I don't have like you
know I can't like say like top five or
anything like that but it's like this is
definitely one of the best Stephen King
adaptations I think and I was watching
some other reviews of it and I'm kind of
glad that a lot of movie reviewers even
like you know dudes much younger than us
do seem to have a lot of appreciation
for this movie and that makes me happy
because I feel like it didn't really do
very well at the time and it kind of got
forgotten about but this is definitely
definitely because there were a lot of
shitty Stephen King out a lot of good
ones too but most of them were kind of
shitty forgotten was actually religious
guys don't know if the stories about
it's about a kid in high school whose
his parents won't let him get a car but
he does it anyway he buys a car with
with not much money and buys old jalopy
turns out that the jalopies haunted
possessed I guess what it possesses the
moniker yeah it does a lot of weird
stuff in the book it the book it does
more than what it doesn't in the movie
but it was the movie pretty much
captures it I mean it leaves some stuff
out but it's pretty cool I think this is
actually a pretty faithful adaptation I
mean they kind of changed the Christine
Zorich
story yeah um a little bit but I think
you know some stuff that works in a book
and I think I've probably mentioned this
on a lot of the shows about Stephen King
adaptations stuff that works in a book
doesn't always work in a movie so I
think the choices they made were
probably right the right ones this
pretty much follows the beat of the book
and actually when I saw I think I might
have no I was gonna say I think I've
read the book first now the book in the
movie came out in the same year and I'll
explain why that happened in a minute
but I didn't see this in the theater I
didn't see it till it was on cable later
on and I recorded it so I probably read
the book first and honestly when I saw
the movie
it seemed spot-on like it seemed what I
imagined when I was reading the book
like as far as all the characters went
and the setting and everything like that
so I think he did a really good job now
the interesting thing about it is that
John Carpenter was not super jazzed
about doing this one in particular he
was kind of bummed out because you know
he had just done the thing in 1981 which
was like a big deal and that he was
really into it was like a passion
project yeah and kind of fly and it
flops like even critically which is
amazing cuz it was like one of the best
won best movies of all made clearly aged
super well yes it's obviously lasting
obviously way ahead of time because it
just scared the [ __ ] out of me and I was
a kid that gets scared the [ __ ] up my
dad took me see it's good [ __ ] yeah I
was like afterwards he's drunk we're
driving back home you know tamanna
visiting for the summer
down in Mississippi and I was awful
quiet because you have quiet over there
yeah that was weird because yeah that
was I was thinking about me I mean there
are aliens that can come and just absorb
you it was a good one yeah cuz that
seems almost like kind of teetering on
the edge of plausibility it's like that
yeah it totally happened yeah like the
blob it's basically a modified version
of the blob so John Carpenter was kind
of like bummed out that the movie hadn't
done as well as he wanted because he had
been so excited about it so he was
actually working on an adaptation of
firestarter of all things but then that
kind of fell through obviously it got
made later on with a different director
another good movie yeah it is actually a
pretty decent adaptation I think I mean
both of these accent I like Kristine
better but fire starters get to I got to
get Christina Christina Firestar
start her on steelbook that still was
steelbook blu-ray yeah I think that
would be good and then that's a
carpenter flick that one yeah oh yeah
firestarter is is it no yeah like I said
he was initially attached that project
but then it fell through and then it
yeah I've got mainly that's still a good
one it kind of feels like like a
carpenter flick anyway it does kind of
you probably like picked up some of his
ideas woman yeah but yeah so he wasn't
like super jazzed about doing Christine
he said it was just a job you know he
was still kind of in the dumps about the
thing not doing as well as he wanted but
in the end he decided to go and do this
now the interesting thing about this is
that the book of Christine was not out
when this movie went into production I
know that what ended up happening with
Stephen King was like still working on
some [ __ ] and obviously they had made so
many successful adaptations of his work
like kitchen that they done carry and
all this other stuff so you know people
were coming to him going well have you
got anything that's coming out soon that
we can you know option so that we can
make a movie out of it like before the
book comes out so he goes okay well I
have Christine and I have Cujo so he
offers it and the people were like men
they didn't really want to do Cujo but
they said Oh Christine sounds kind of
good now I think it was maybe the
producer like when they said well what's
the movie about he's like well it's like
a demonic car he's thank you for real
yeah it was a dumb idea but then like
they read his book and then they read
like the screenplay of it I think that
the guy that wrote the screenplay was
the same guy that did the screen
adaptation for Salem's Lot yeah I'm
pretty sure that's got bad ways to write
good so that's the same guy and so they
got him to do the screen treatment for
Christine as I said the book the movie
actually came out earlier in the year
and then I think the book came out like
late in the year like only a couple
months later so the movie actually came
out a little bit before the book did now
the interesting and one of my favorite
things about this other than john
carpenter's direction and john comfort
is john carpenter's score in this which
i love i love like the music and the
sound effects and stuff is i think that
the cast is my favorite part
keith gordon yeah as Arnie Cunningham is
fantastic now what's interesting about
this is that he was not the first pick
do you know who was the first pick Scott
Baio yeah I don't think it would work no
yeah for you guys that don't
Arne who is the guy who is the kid who
buys the car he's a real nerd he's a
nice guy
but likable and super loser yeah he's in
the chest yeah yeah yeah and stuff
now his best friend is a jock yeah you
know who can't protects you dang ball
player yeah yeah he's got it all got the
hot girlfriend it's got the hot car and
everything but he keeps this arnie from
getting beat up yeah well he buys this
demonic car he buys it from the guy
what's the guy's name
Arnel maybe no that's the that's the
garage getcha garage it wasn't even the
guys obey what's his last name
Labe it was George I think it was George
so baby because they've you they kind of
like Anton LaVey well in the book there
was two brothers and like the guy that
yeah I'd in the car was not the guy you
know what I mean in the movie they made
it was like oh my brother this was my
brother's car and he died and it blah
blah blah in the book that guy who got
owned the car sold sold it - yeah like
yeah and then he died later in the I
thought the book was better the guy was
I remember he was eaten up with cancer
wasn't he
he was dying heating up of cancer it's
something I know uh maybe it was I
thought it might have been like lung
cancer or something cuz you it's been a
long time since I've read the book and
he's a soul eater eaten up [ __ ] burnt
out basically an evil gray sir ya know
for you guys too young to know degreaser
is that was a 1950s goth basically
[ __ ] you know big old duck ass hair
yeah and they were you know motorcycles
and cars and they were kind of the rough
kids I guess you could say you know like
Fonz okay except not as cool now it's
not as nice as yeah the link you see
grease it was like you know one of the
guys anyway which we had to grease to
house a good one and I kind of look I
also have to even though it's bad
sometimes the musical [ __ ] kidney
anyway so this old greaser cells in this
burnout old 50s it's a fury I think when
in a theory yeah from the 50s and he
loves this garbage salad it's already a
you have a kid
and then soon as he sells it a dude dies
with his car is awful strange and it
starts doing weird things like odometer
running backwards he's working on it but
the car gets better as he drives it he
doesn't really remember fixing certain
things yeah and they got kind of go into
that little bit in the book where it's
like he's like did I fix that remember
in the movie they kind of referred to it
because you know like Darnell comes into
the garage like where he's fixing car up
and he's like you know he put in new
windshield wipers over a busted
windshield it's like he's just going at
things all combine yeah and he wasn't
sure how he's gonna replace this
windshield cuz it was around here is
rounded on the edges it was cracked and
you couldn't get that anymore but he
just noticed that I think the cracks
were getting smaller yeah and eventually
he didn't have to replace it but he was
it was weird he drive it in to play old
50's music and he'd feel like he was
getting in love with this car yeah call
it was like loving on him and [ __ ] as
he's driving it and he starts getting
obsessed with his car and Arnie slowly
starts losing all his acne yeah and he
starts getting a little more buffed out
and he starts to slowly become a greaser
yeah and he starts to actually not he
starts to eventually go from being kada
a nerd into being cool and then he kind
of morphs into being a [ __ ] dick yeah
should have stopped right there no but
then he goes a little too real arrogant
[ __ ] dick he's got all these enemies
in his past from when he was a nerd
picking on him and then weird [ __ ]
happens these enemies they get killed
and I can't spoil everything if you
haven't seen the movie you should
probably go see the book we should just
yeah you know it's an old movie car goes
out and kills people it's implied I
think maybe he was in the car certain
times when people got well yeah I should
say that lace is the book sometimes the
book and the movie start to blur with me
well like I said the book in the movie
are pretty similar as in like all the
plot points and stuff the book is gory
er than the movie the movie actually
isn't really all that gory surprisingly
um the ending is different in the book
which actually I think the movie ending
might be a little bit better in this in
the book Arnie doesn't get killed he's
not in Christine when Christine gets
fished right Dennis and Lea rookies
actually gets killed somewhere else in
another car wreck later on I think his
mom gets killed too but that doesn't
happen in the movie maybe he's in
another what really kind of let me down
in the movie is that in the book
overtime as already becomes more more I
guess you could say possessed and more
evil he starts seeing lebay yeah in the
bay starts riding with him in the
passenger seat he's coven undead version
of labate kind of sometimes he's
slightly kind of robbed me yeah he's all
zombie looking and in the book he gives
him some awesome [ __ ] advice on
people over and how to be a badass [ __ ]
how these [ __ ] are all evil and you
know got to get even with them and and
yeah it's like it's it's kind of like
something from the dark side of the
force or a Star Wars movie with the Sith
and [ __ ]
yeah he's kind of like the Emperor yes
you know telling him to go out and do
[ __ ] you don't [ __ ] these people up and
but he's doing it in a 1950s greaser way
which is really weird yeah and they're
drinking out of the same [ __ ] bottles
and [ __ ] that's right I remember that
from was it rebel yell they were
drinking oh [ __ ] it might if I think I
might be rebel and read the book it
along yeah they were just like rebel
yells like [ __ ] real [ __ ] white
trash redneck [ __ ] I heard it's kind
of since Billy Idol made it famous I
think it's a little better than to use
their like hey we can probably put our
place up now yeah I don't know it's
probably not any more bits might have
been too I don't even I don't even think
I've seen it not that I've been like
looking for you could order it used to
be that you could find it in the South
yeah okay yeah you know that was [ __ ]
you found it out now next time we're in
the liquor store I'm gonna have to link
about looking for you finding out about
a Mississippi you know yeah yeah rebel
yell oh yeah it was like worse than Wild
Turkey by the way even though you're not
saying something even though it wasn't
from the south I think it was actually
distilled on a contract up north from
but they sold it it's a carpetbagger is
it it sounded like something Elvis a
drink
yeah so with his manners
yeah peanut butter banana fried in
butter see I don't like the fried our
whole [ __ ] sandwich and butter but
holy but you could take a peanut butter
sandwich and fried butter no I didn't
very loudly I've done it before
well yeah I don't think I've made it
peanut butter but yeah a friendship oh I
gotta get back to the side track but I
was gonna say that the most significant
I hope we always did yeah
the most significant difference between
the book in the movie and like I said I
think it was probably a good decision
that they changed it for the movie and I
there's a reason why they did and I'll
get into that in a second but in the
book like you said the car as far as I
know as far as I can remember the car
was like normal until lebay died yeah
and then he like possessed the car mean
I don't know like I think lebay said
some stuff some hints that the car
wasn't normal cuz I think it killed some
guys on their wife and his kids yeah it
was it was an evil force and the bay was
kind of joined with it yeah and if you
owned it
and I and it was evidently female if you
owned it it tried to own you yeah and
there was like this tainted love type
experience between you in this car you
would try to kill your girlfriend or you
know and you didn't try to get Ernie's
girlfriend but yeah you didn't want any
other women in your life it was and and
you got they got addicted to it it's
like heroin slowly take it over your
life for something you know it's an
excellent book I think the book add in a
different dimension to it but you know
that's what every movie even even sure
yeah like I said like the movie should
read the book yes like I said that you
know totally it's pretty similar and
stuff like that but like I said in a way
I kind of think that I mean in the movie
they imply that the car was just evil
from the beginning they don't really
they don't they just basically said this
is a demonic car because they show up
rolling off the assembly line in Detroit
and you know immediately somebody's
checking out of the tire and like you
know it slams on his hand it killed a
guy a minute good older guy yeah now the
interesting thing about this too is that
the Plymouth Fury they they had 24
Plymouth's yeah for this movie now they
couldn't all my van all of the plymouth
lorry yes well no because what happened
was they because they didn't make that
many Furies he had to use others he had
to use like a plymouth belvedere and a
couple of other type because they looked
very similar yeah
now the Plymouth Fury was never not
famous really well that's why Stephen
King wanted it to be a Plymouth Fury he
said I wanted a car that was kind of
like forgotten about that didn't have
any other kind of thing and so you know
so he could kind of make his own iconic
thing now the Plymouth Fury was never
and as far as I know the Belvedere never
came out in that color in that red it
was they were all beige yeah it was
something to you even when I was in high
school you know you never want to be
caught dead something like that you know
then when I go to down south Mississippi
and sometimes borrow my dead
grandmother's car drive around yeah it
was a Plymouth Satellite
and [ __ ] it look at me crazy driving
m6 me a satellite I think it was like a
68 or 65 yeah it was a weird metallic
boo baby blue metallic rag top kind of a
smaller kind of a car really for its
area but the the the the fury the
Plymouth fear was a [ __ ] land yacht
for those you they're enormous
yeah for those of you in Europe there's
just no experience yeah it's like a boat
it's like they're steering a gigantic
but letting the Titanic through the
street didn't even big for the American
Road really it was it was very wide and
they always oversteer you just steer
them in the [ __ ] whole chassis
continuing to conic turn sideways even
though you're going straight and um
Victor because it real suspensions and
they just that's some crazy [ __ ] they
weren't they were never built to drive
fast you had to try the thing slow like
a old man yeah but it felt like you know
how you have that sensation when you get
out of your house and then you get in
the car and you leave your house never
really have that sensation you still
feel like it's an extension is the
extension of the house you just want
another room that movies are yelling
jelena passenger hand me that yes you
can literally have cigarette they have
sex in the backseat we used to do that
kind of [ __ ] those big old cars without
your without your foot hitting no gear a
fire oh you know I've seen foreigners
get in those old cars you know back in
the 90s and you know if I could live in
Boston the friend of mine had was a big
old things trying to it was a big old
[ __ ] Cadillac trying to drive that
thing around Boston that's what I
learned earlier is my grandfather's the
fans on it [ __ ] huge I couldn't like
turn it or Park it I'm just like holy
crap this is just like they burned a lot
of gasoline had a lot of torque they
weren't fast but they were strong yeah
not much brakes you had to plan ahead
I'm gonna have to stop how to stop up
there yeah kind of like easy yeah the
interesting thing and another thing that
was interesting about this movie was
that it was made in 1983 but it was set
in 1978 for whatever reason um and when
RNA goes to buy the car and it's all
[ __ ] up and junky and everything like
that I think he buys it for in the book
it was $250 I think that was a
comparable amount um and Dennis tries to
talk him out him because he's like oh
it's a hunk of junk you'd get a better
car for that and all this other kind of
[ __ ] but I feel like nowadays if you
found a car like that and if you knew
how to restore it and stuff I don't
think anybody would get all up in your
grill about paying $250 for a car like
that if you could restore it because
holy crap everybody be like holy [ __ ]
look at that thing
the thing is this story is taking place
in a time where that was just an old
that's what I'm saying
words that's one thing that's like you
know maybe people nowadays can't relate
to you but like back then they're like
oh that was just some old person like
cool [ __ ] car there was lots of the
those were all being crunched yeah and
people were happy that they were being
crushed because they they were from
another era and really they just
shouldn't be shouldn't have really been
on the road I mean they were huge they
couldn't stop they didn't have much
safety you know features to them they
know crumple zones if you wrecked that
car chances are you got
killed and you killed a bunch of other
people with him yeah marks were really
not the dashboards the the the steering
wheels the steering columns none of that
stuff would break you would hit it in it
would just go through you it was so so
my grandmother's brother died that way
yeah yeah and he was 17 and you just
waste so much you know somebody could
rear-end you at relatively low speeds
and there it could kill him yeah oh yeah
just crush their car well yeah remember
I had that girl Bruin tree rent my
Mustang back like in Webb's at 2013 2014
and it totaled her car yeah it was just
scratch the paint off my bumper and she
was in when I was a little bitty uh I'd
forgot what that thing was it was a
little bitty Japanese car a little
subcompact I forgot what it was I felt
some kaboom I hit like then it turned
back and I saw a car just crushed like
an accordion yeah she didn't have any
insurance or anything but well there
made the crunch now is a question even
my car I had a Nissan and it was like
not even that new in 2004 and I hit
somebody and the whole front end was
smushed it was totaled but I was totally
fine like everything was done away from
I had just 94 yeah it was a 94 Mustang I
bought it for cheap with a blow motor
rebuilt the motor redid everything dual
[ __ ] shorty exhaust with thrush
mufflers on it and everything good
wheels I was gonna put that damn
supercharger out a Thunderbird in it but
one thing led to another because it was
the v6 it wasn't a v8 but it just it was
heavy brighterdayz standards it just
became impractical yeah ya know I mean
it's just a smaller lighter car just
makes so much more I drove it a few
times and it was like so heavy and so
low to the ground yeah that even when I
was going like I felt like I had to like
push the gas like all the way down like
to go ahead like at a normal speed you
did it oh the controls were all because
I was used to driving like a Honda Fit
no you don't like a hundred miles an
hour I felt like I was in an airplane
you know
yeah the hanafuda faster than this
Mustang it was that but the Mustang
looked and
shaddup I mean well the thing that when
you wrote it when you drove it was like
riding in a bomber oh yeah cuz my
exhaust I mean new cars I could like if
I'm not paying attention to the to the
speed thing I'm just like I'll go
[ __ ] I'm going 110 miles an hour that
yeah yeah yeah 110 miles an hour and a
94 Mustang feels like 200 that's what I
mean like yeah so I I felt like it was
kind of like it was really hard because
I had a driver for a while after my I
got channel yeah but yeah so know what I
was gonna say was that one of the
reasons that they changed the whole
thing of the book where you know in the
book it was là-bas ghost essentially
that was like you know hanging out with
him and talking to him and getting to do
getting him to do things and kind of
possessing him and changing his
personality and stuff one of the reasons
they didn't want to do that was because
of an American Werewolf in London
because that had just come out and that
had that whole like subplot about his
dead friend coming back and getting like
you know more and more like decayed as
the movie went on and like telling him
things and giving him advice and stuff
so they didn't want to look like they
were ripping that off so they decided
that they were gonna make the car just
like evil from the beginning and not
really explain it it was just like a
possessed car that was you know just
came off the line that way it was like
born bad or whatever so yeah so that was
why they did that and another thing too
that I don't know I feel like what I was
saying before about the casting being
like the best part of this and I think
we went off on a tangent but I was
saying yeah they wanted Scott Baio for
Arnie they wanted Brooke Shields for Lee
the girlfriend and they wanted actually
Kevin Bacon was gonna be Dennis and he
was actually hired but then he got the
lead in Footloose so he said he couldn't
do it so then they got um john stockwell
I think his name is he's better for that
role anyway yeah and so like I said it
almost seemed like even though pretty
much nobody was like the main choice cuz
John Carpenter was basically like Scott
Baio and Brooke Shields he's like no
he's like I want actors that aren't
really that well-known
people can relate to them better when I
see that guy just think of that role
yeah I mean he was in other movies I
think he was in back-to-school with
Rodney Dangerfield and stuff yeah
there's nobody he actually went into
directing later on as as did john
stockwell they both went and john
stockwell was actually in my science
project which if you haven't seen that
that's another [ __ ] movie that i love
from the 80s we should do one for that
if I can find it it's kind of one that a
lot of people don't talk about Dennis
[ __ ] Hopper isn't it it's so good it
was good about him is that he could pull
off being a nerd but then he could also
pull off that was the best thing about
it pull off being a psychopath gray sir
totally believable like and he was
likable either way
almost it's like when he was a nerd at
the beginning again he was nerdy and you
could understand why he got beat up but
he was also like a really likable
character also the friendship between
him and Dennis was really good really
believable I mean they grown up together
clearly I don't know if they mentioned
that outright yeah that look they grew
up for the young age yeah it took two
different paths right but they were
still like looked out for you there all
the time more like a really nice
friendship he almost he was actually a
little bit more near nerdy in the book
yeah in the book he was like almost
borderline Asperger's or something yeah
you know and he had a lot of acne and he
was super super skinny before when I
remember us once that car got ahold of
him he bumped up did yeah anyway and his
skin cleared up and yeah yeah yeah and
he didn't work out he but he just got
stronger and bigger we started throwing
his dad around yeah remember that yeah
he did that in the movie too yeah well
he actually like punched his dad or
smacked is that yeah some point but um
well yeah in the book in the book they
were implying that he was taking on all
of LA Bay's characteristics because it
was one point in the book where he was
out working on the car doing something
and he pulled his back so he ended up
wearing a back brace just like lebay
that's right so he was taking over his
benzo I was trying to merge with him
yeah yeah yeah that's right so that was
like that was not what they did in the
movie and like I said I don't actually
mind that change it was good enough yeah
it worked I know why they did it yeah
and honestly the the end of the movie I
actually kind of liked better because
throughout the whole entire movie
you're not really sure if well you are
kind of sure but you he wanted to make
it ambiguous whether Arnie was in the
car when it killed people or whether he
wasn't in the car so what they did was
that they blacked out all the windows
when they were doing the kill scenes so
that you wouldn't be able to see the
stunt driver but also the stunt driver
couldn't see how to drop it so when you
saw you know the the iconic scene where
he killed some of the bullies that had
[ __ ] up the car and it's like in that
gas station in the gas station blows up
and then Christine comes out and she's
on fire there was a guy in there drive
like a stunt guy and they're driving
that and he couldn't see where in the
book he wasn't in that car sometimes
orally I don't think he was in that car
well I think in the movie they kind of
implied that most of the time he wasn't
in the car because a few times he was
somewhere else oh yeah but in the book
it also comes back he says well what was
eyes own doubt and did I yeah like he
didn't remember he was probably in the
car in this one I feel like they made
him more of an innocent bystander
because until the end I think when like
buddy repperton got run over when likes
when Moochie got run over I don't think
he was in the car because wasn't he use
doing [ __ ] for will Darnell so he was
out of town well in the movie they make
it they make it I remembered them making
it clear that he wasn't in the car yeah
I'm already sure he wasn't I think in
the book it was more ambiguous yeah that
he may have been in the car business
remember he couldn't remember but
remember his long time ago I haven't
read that book I logged off yeah but it
was excellent book it was definitely as
good as the shining book yeah definitely
I liked it you know what I mean and it's
like I have to give a shout-out to to
the guy I think he's passed away now and
I can't run for the actor's name but the
guy that played will Darnell the kid the
guy that runs garage well Ernie like I
love that guy that wasn't a character
that was a reality for me well because
growing up I was dealing with those guys
well that's bad Matty
it was a man it was a man's duty to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] to teenagers
he's a guy and I'm just saying like and
at one point like you think that he's
kind of softening up a little bit toward
Arnie yeah and he says something like
he's like well you know if you want he's
like you know when I told you you could
like you know fix your car with this
doesn't judge me you can't like you know
yes all of my stuff and everything but
then he was saying something like yeah
you know he kind of started to warm to
Arnie in the end a bit time back though
then he says something like he says
something like you know oh well you know
if you could do some stuff around here
like put the toilet paper and little
spools [ __ ] like that yeah yeah and then
you know maybe I'll even throw in a few
bucks and you get nice often and are
nice like well I'm gonna think about
well don't think about it too hard I'm
gonna be like that yes true idea I was
influenced by that generation yeah you
know I mean I get that like like I said
he reminds me some of these Millennials
my family yes
so that's I think that's why I find that
character so funny that he's just like
it's just so grouchy it was about being
hard but being fair and keeping young
bucks in line about yeah you just can't
you just can't let these young guys do
where the [ __ ] they want to do or
they'll end up just being [ __ ] up yeah
you have to manage that [ __ ] okay even
Nietzsche says they had to manage that
[ __ ] cuz they prepare their words he is
to manage that [ __ ] okay
you gotta put rules on those young guys
that way that makes him stronger and
makes them better and then you can take
the rules away and then they can learn
it they can be strong enough to break
rules or make their own rules you can't
just raise it raise a young dude without
any rules him be weak but yeah so like I
was saying about y'all yo man no
tomorrow but like I was saying like he
just has some of the best lines and he's
so funny it's like I just loved away
like he comes in and he's looking at
Christine who's all [ __ ] up cuz he
hasn't Arnie hasn't really fixed her up
yet yeah he's looking at like you know
you can't polish a turkey buzzer can I
saw that Mythbusters hold on I mean yeah
oh dude knows India yeah that piece of
[ __ ] just so so funny but like there's
some really [ __ ] great lines in this
and you know he's great in it [ __ ] him
like I said Keith Gordon is great and as
Arnie in it like even when he gets kind
of like cool later on like he has some
great [ __ ] lines and it's just this
is just one of the movies like I said
this is one of my 80s comfort movies
yeah I was gonna say that there's a lot
of stuff about this movie that khana
it's very very comforting execute like I
said I've taped it off cable and I
watched it a million zillion it's the
story of it's the structure of the story
the story itself and the way it's acted
yeah there's nothing really in here to
kind of shatter you know oh what's a
good way to put it there's nothing in
here to take you out of the movie well
it's a very simple is very
straightforward
I mean you kind of know where it's gonna
go but that's okay that's fine you know
what I mean it's a revenge story and
like I said I think the thing that
really elevates it you know other than
John Carpenter's direction and his score
and everything is the cast and I think
the cast is like really really good and
they all work really well me together I
see it again yeah well it's on shudder
at the moment um like I said my favorite
part about it is like Arnie and Dennis's
like friendship and like how because
it's totally it's totally believable
yeah go watch a movie if you like the
movie I think you'll like it it's on
shudder yeah shudder needs to start
sponsoring us we don't get this every
time we started talking with please
movie we mentioned shudder well you got
some it got some bimbo on there running
shutter shutters there her sponsor why
don't we yeah she's got 20 thousands my
shudder money won anyway yeah go you can
go watch that on shudder you can watch
it if you can find it you know I think
you could probably watch it the prior
rent in that off in YouTube to I would
choose price yeah it is yeah watch if
you like it watch read the book yeah
yeah the book guy is actually better I'm
gonna say this well the book is
book is always a vanity but but I think
this is a like a really faithful
adaptation and I actually think it's
easily top 10 maybe even top 5 like
Stephen King adaptations I mean it's
just really really good and you know
like I said everything when I was
reading the book and seeing the movie
like a lot of it I mean the reason that
maybe we can't remember like what
happened in the movie or what happened
in the book was just because it was so
similar because I mean John Carpenter
did a really good job other than a
couple of changes and you know I
understand why they made them yeah if
you like The Shining don't think you
know the book unless you read the book
that's very different well yeah it is
that same story just that there's a
whole lot more yeah this is not this is
not like that not like that this is a
pretty straightforward pretty close
pretty close yeah but yeah I like it
like I said I feel like it's an
underrated Stephen King adaptation and
underrated John Carpenter baby so if you
have yeah definitely go check it out cuz
I got a carpeting a better movie yeah
and I think it's like one of the Oh
another thing I was gonna say to just
like right before the end was that
remember how I said like it wasn't very
gory which is like really surprising
yeah they were so concerned that it
wasn't gory enough I mean they the
studio wanted an r-rating which is weird
because nowadays every but they want
everything to be pg-13 but back then
they said it would be better it's a
horror movie they want our rating so
they could get like all the teenagers
want to go see it yeah so they were
worried that it wouldn't be gory enough
to get an R rating so then they went
back and just put like a whole bunch of
swearing yeah it's like as so
everything's [ __ ] this punching
hand that like so everything you sweat
that's why there's so much swear I was
in the book though it was yeah but
that's why they put that in the movie
specifically because they wanted to get
an artery wouldn't surprise me is if you
see if we see a relaunch of Kristine
with all the Stephen Kevin you know what
I was watching a review the other day
well I heard you could do this [ __ ]
right now adays they were remaking
firestarter I don't understand though
but the interesting thing about it
though it's like even like when
Christine is like regenerating herself
that still looks fantastic a good job no
CGI they did it with hydraulics and
Manning they played it back yeah and
then they ran the film in Reverse like
they shot it upside
like some plastic maladies really good
nowadays though you could really extend
those action scenes of the compact with
the car well you can go long you can
make it yeah you can do it you could do
it because a lot of it wasn't that
memory and I definitely would put lebay
back in the [ __ ] story yeah so make
it like the two brothers instead of just
one guy yeah cuz it was two brothers as
well was yeah and then the undead lebay
trying to take over and the possession
[ __ ] things and visions his
remembering he was having visions yeah
it wouldn't surprise it wouldn't
surprise me actually and I think in the
book didn't Dennis got into the car like
before Arnie even bought it and I
thought he had a vision which was one of
the reasons why you already don't buy it
because he got it like a really bad
thing yeah when you read it nurse all
the little details in the car is a lot
creepier well I think the first and the
third act of the book are from Dennis's
point of view like the middle is like
you know from third-person but I think
the first so that's all from his point
of view so he's like talking a lot about
his friendship with Arnie and how its
how Arnie is changing like from his
point of view yeah but like all the
killings and stuff in the middle of
that's all from the third person right
do it wrap it up yes uh as I said this
is on shudder right now if you want to
go check it out or you can rent it on
YouTube I believe it's 399 so go check
it out if you haven't seen it arrays
from 1983 that will do it for our latest
movie a retrospective and let's see if
you like the show like share subscribe
and all your social media if you'd like
to financially support ship and go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar
sidebar we can go to a PayPal account if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
remember these movie retrospectives come
out every Friday or Thursday if you're a
patron
we also have 13 o'clock matinee comes
out every Sunday and our regular
episodes which are usually true-crime a
paranormal they come out every Tuesday
we will see you next time bye